متلازمه الهرس شبح جديد يلاحق الاطفال
الناجين هنا في عموم مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
هناك العديد من الاصابات بهذه المرض وهناك
العديد من الاطفال المهددين ببطر الاطراف
نتيجه هذه
الاصابات طبعا نحن الان في مشفى الشفاء
كان من المفترض ان ندخل الى جناح الاطفال
هنا في هذا المشفى ولكن قبل اجراء عمليه
البث هذه لاحظنا ان
الحاله النفسيه للاطفال لا تسمح بتصويرهم
الان يعني الاطفال بصراحه بحاله يرفوا
بحاله يرثى لها بحاله مزريه جدا نفسيا
وجسديا طبعا
الاصابات يعني كثيره في فئه الاطفال هناك
يعني اصابات
يعني غير جسديه وهي اصابه العائله هناك
العديد من الاطفال الحقيقه فقدوا اهلهم
والى حد هذه اللحظه لا يعلمون انهم فقدوا
اهلهم ولكن يعلمون انهم من الممكن ان ان
يفقدوا اطرافهم نتيجه هذه الاصابات يعني
حقيقه
الالام التي يشعر بها صعبه جدا
هناك العديد من الاصابات التي تحتاج
لاجهزه طبيه متطوره الى حد هذه اللحظه
رعايه هؤلاء الاطفال هل تتم بصوره فرديه
ام من هناك جهات او منظمات يمكن ان تقدم
المزيد من الدعم لهم
نعم يعني في الحقيقه الوضع الطبي هنا في
عموم شمال غرب سوريا ودعني اتحدث هنا في
مشفى الشفاء يعني من ناحيه الاجهزه الطبيه
هناك
عجز في موضوع الاجهزه الطبيه وخصوصا في
موضوع الاجهزه المتعلقه بامراض الكلى وهذا
يعني وهذا الاختصاص يعني
هو الاكثر
طلبا هنا بعد حادثه الزلزال الذي ضربت
المنطقه خصوصا لمصابين متلازمه الهرس طبعا
هناك عجز في موضوع الاجهزه اما بالنسبه
لعمل المنظمات
المنظمات تاتي الى الى المشافي تقدم بعض
الهدايا للاطفال الهدايا
العينيه او الهدايا الرمزيه للاطفال اما
من الناحيه الطبيه فهناك عجز في الحقيقه
من ناحيه الاجهزه الطبيه هناك مناشدات
تطلق من شمال غرب لا يزال الاطباء هنا في
شمال غرب سوريا يطلقون المناشدات للخارج
بالاسراع بادخال الاجهزه الطبيه لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه